I wanna talk about the dangers of being a stay at home mom
as a stay at home mom in a Bravo fan
and we're gonna relate this to Bravo Summerhouse and Kyle and Amanda
I have always said that being a stay at home mom
is a very dangerous position to put yourself in
and it really really really does relies on your partner
their ego and their sense of power dynamics
catch you up to speed about Kyle and Amanda
Kyle started his own company
Lover Boy and as that company started game momentum
he asked his then fiance
now wife to quit her job to come help him full time at Loverboy
she now
I believe is the director or creative director or the director of marketing
maybe both however
fast forward to present time
they've been married now for a year or two
and they're starting to be cracks in the marriage
and one of the things I'm starting to notice is that Kyle resents Amanda
for depending on him for an income
he also resents her and belittles her because he thinks he has full ownership
full money making capabilities and this company is his own
even though he asked his wife to leave her other paying job
to come join his business that they would build together
he clearly doesn't see it as both of their businesses
my husband is a business owner
I have never like gone to work with him in a full time capacity
but I have dabbled here and there and he watches the show with me
and we were deconstructing this and he was like
there is such a reality that money comes with entitlement
even if you don't want it to
you almost have to check yourself
because my husband has gotten in really busy times of his business
where he feels that he is working so hard or making so much money
that he feels entitled to an easier time at home
we've talked through that and he's a very emotionally mature human being
so like we're fine
but Kyle and Amanda are not fine
because you're watching this power dynamic
dissolve the relationship into disgust
into resentment
and it is eating away at the affection
that both of these people have for each other
if they want this to continue in a healthy way
Kyle needs to admit that he couldn't do this at all without Amanda
and give her her fair due and respect necessary
and realize that just because you're bringing home the bacon
doesn't mean you get to drop all of your responsibilities as a husband
and a potential father
and Amanda needs to make sure that she is willing to deal with this man's ego
and doesn't wanna have her own little pot of gold on the side
where she can get the respect and monetary compensation
that she may need one day
when Mister Kyle
she's sick of dealing with him
is a classic cautionary tale for stay at home moms
for people who could end up in a financial abusive situation
with money comes entitlement
comes power
and if there's too much of an unequal power dynamic within a relationship
that is a right possibility for abuse